mental illness the thing actors pretend
to have in order to win oscars
now in real life mental health can be
something of a touchy topic we don't
like to talk about it much and as one
psychiatrist explains when we do
we don't talk about it well stigma still
is a very big issue
it manifests itself in the ways that we
think and talk about the
the mentally ill and in the terms the
words
that we use to describe them for
instance
wacko psycho cray-cray
okay okay first hearing a bearded
middle-aged man used the term cray-cray
may have already killed that word
forever
it's like when your mom says something
is on fleek it's done
it's just over at that point but second
he is right
cray cray is a terrible name to call
someone with mental illness
although it is an excellent name for a
cartoon crayfish who just won a
scuttling contest
you did it cray cray you won the race
the point is we don't don't we don't
talk about mental illness well
sometimes even tv personalities with
doctor in their names can get it
disastrously wrong
on the next dr oz everybody wants to
know am i normal
or nuts should you be worried this
behavior is
it's not normal have you gone completely
insane i mean sir have you gone
completely insane completely insane
people
go outside suck on a rock and bark at
the moon
what the is wrong with you sucking
on a rock and barking at the moon is not
a sign that someone's mentally ill it's
a sign that they are a wolf with an iron
deficiency
you're thinking of anemic wolves dr phil
you're getting confused
but perhaps the clearest sign of just
how little we want to talk about mental
health is that one of the only times
it's actively brought up
is as we've seen yet again this week in
the aftermath of a mass shooting
as a means of steering the conversation
away from gun control
this isn't guns this is about really
mental illness
in many of these shootings we have
people who have mental disturbances
do we need to do a better job in mental
health you bet we do
yeah it seems there is nothing like a
mass shooting to suddenly spark
political interest in mental health
although it's worth noting that governor
huckabee's state
got a grade of d minus on mental health
care while he was in office
and you can't lecture people on
something you've got a d-minus in
it's like passionately delivering a
speech on proper english grammar by
saying
we need to thunk better about how we
does word stuff
we need to get it did and the
aftermath of a mass shooting might
actually be the worst time to talk about
mental health
because for the record the vast majority
of mentally ill people
are non-violent and the vast majority of
gun violence is committed by
non-mentally ill people in fact mentally
ill people are far likely to be the
victims of violence
rather than the perpetrators so the fact
we tend to only discuss mental health in
a mass shooting context
is deeply misleading it would be like if
the only time we talked about coca-cola
it were in the context of this i'm
standing here with this ice-cold
thirst-quenching
deliciously satisfying coca-cola and it
actually
tastes better now more than ever coke
is it sure sure
that happened and coke was undeniably
involved in it
but most cans of coke are not that one
and it would be unfair if every time you
thought of coke you thought of that
but if now is our only opportunity to
have a public discussion about mental
health then perhaps we should do it
because in 2013 an estimated 43.8
million american adults dealt with a
mental illness and an estimated 10
million of us suffer from
a serious mental illness each year 10
million
that's almost as many people as live in
greece and most of us know
a lot more about greece than we know
about our mental health system
think about it you know at least three
things about greece its economy is
collapsing
yani's from there and greek yogurt
tastes like the ice cream they make in a
town where dancing is illegal
you know at least three and when you
look
at how our current system deals with
severe mental illness you'll quickly
realize it's a mess and it always has
been
we used to lock people up in asylums
which were often so bad they were known
as snake pits
and that doesn't sound like an
attractive place to live even if you're
a snake
you'd want some kind of snake loft or
snake bungalow
i don't know i'm no real a snake agent
and and then and then and then in the
1960s
president kennedy signed a bill to try
and close as many of those asylums as
possible
under this legislation custodial mental
institutions
will be replaced by therapeutic centers
it should be possible within a decade or
two
to reduce the number of patients and
mental institutions
by 50 or more and that was a really good
idea because when you see
horrible places doing unspeakable things
to people you are supposed to try and
shut them down
that's why there are so few quiznos left
but
but before you get too proud of the fact
that we shut those snake pits down it
turns out
we never followed through and properly
funded the community mental health
centers jfk had wanted to replace them
all of those patients had to go
somewhere and some of the places they
wound up
are shocking for instance a few years
ago the ap
found that nearly 125 000 young and
middle-aged mental health patients
were being placed in nursing homes and
it's not
a great idea to just stick a young
person in with some old people
and then hope for the best it's like
casting taylor lautner in the new
best exotic marigold hotel movie it's
unsuitable for everybody
involved in it and some states have been
involved in something called
greyhound therapy and unfortunately that
does not mean
getting to hug a trembling dog who's 98
bone and gristle
it's an even worse kind of greyhound the
kind with four wheels and a broken
toilet
this is ross and neal the only
state-run psychiatric hospital in
southern nevada
ross and neil has been accused of
greyhound therapy
a practice critics call unthinkable
discharging seriously ill patients too
soon
then supplying them with a one-way bus
ticket
out of town i'm sorry but you cannot
just put people you'd rather not see on
a bus to another city
if you could that's how every breakup
would end
look look greta it's not you it's me but
on the other hand i think you're going
to really enjoy your new life in
syracuse
and we have not even got into the most
depressingly common place
that people with mental illnesses can
end up two million people with mental
illness go to state and local jails
every year
that's meant there's now ten times more
people behind bars
than in state funded psychiatric
treatment
that is terrible finding out jails are
our largest provider of mental health
treatment is like finding out lil wayne
lyrics
are our greatest source of sexual
education no darren you can't smack it
up flip it like a spatula
where did you even learn that what does
it mean flip
it like a spatula would you like it if i
did that to your mother no you wouldn't
you wouldn't darren so don't say it
look look using the criminal justice
system to treat the mentally ill isn't
just
ineffective it's expensive and it's
dangerous
because often when someone is having a
mental health emergency the police will
be called
and that can end tragically by some
estimates an incredible
half of all incidents involving the
police use of deadly force
involve a mentally ill person and to
their credit
some police departments are changing the
way they do things even creating special
units like this one
these officers are experts in what's
called crisis intervention training
would you say that you really don't want
to die but you want the pain to stop
would that be okay and you're willing to
get some help today
this woman agrees to get help we'll go
in there together
you'll ride with us we're in an unmarked
car it's all part of a pioneering
program where the mentally ill
are diverted out of jails and into
treatment
okay well that seems really good but
calling it a pioneering program is a
little heartbreaking
pioneering ideas should not be
completely obvious things we should have
been doing all along they should be
outlandish things that push the limits
of the possible
like a fitted sheet that's easy to fold
or
marshmallow airbags or a sex doll
without such
judgy eyes don't look at me like that
linda
i'm lonely and we both know it
unfortunately only 15
of law enforcement agencies even have
crisis intervention training programs
let alone special units and taking that
training is typically voluntary
and how can something so essential to
your job be voluntary
take the mascot for the tampa bay rays
we don't let him decide whether or not
to wear that costume because without it
things can get ugly fast it's important
for doing his job right
and look that's just a tiny fix our
whole system needs a massive overhaul
which won't be easy the public safety
net for the mentally ill spans medicaid
which is different across the country
eight federal agencies who administer
112 different programs that in some way
touch on mental health
and the social service agencies in each
of the 50 states
it is a cluster except that's an insult
to cluster
because at least in them there's the
potential of a satisfying ending
this is more of a frustrating cluster
dry hump of some kind
and that's not to say there aren't
programs that work
let's look at just one assertive
community treatment
it's designed to let those with serious
mental illnesses live in the community
by providing regular in-home visits
and help coordinate coordinating
assistance in things like housing
and employment listen to just one social
worker explain how it can work
what makes mental health might not just
be a visit to your psychiatrist it might
also mean
having your entitlements in place or it
might mean
having your rent paid on time so instead
of
meeting with a person and talking about
how they're doing
how they feel um on once a month or
twice a month what we do is everything
that it takes to keep people in the
community living independently
that's fantastic everything it takes
sounds like a much better option than
what we've apparently been trying which
is nothing
not anything very few things not much
and prison
and yet in many states assertive
community treatment programs are in
jeopardy thanks to everything from
budget cuts to medicaid reimbursement
problems
despite the fact a study found that
these programs pretty much
pay for themselves which is fantastic
government programs are like graduate
students on a first date
if they are able to pay for themselves
it's a miracle
and look again that's just one program
there are many more designed for many
different levels of need and we as a
society
we have to figure out how to fund them
not just because it makes fiscal sense
but because it would save lives and if i
remember rightly
there are some politicians who claim to
be pretty motivated to address this
problem
this isn't guns this is about really
mental illness and many of these
shootings we have people who have uh
mental disturbances do we need to do a
better job in mental health
you bet we do okay fine do it then
because if we're going to constantly use
mentally ill people to dodge
conversations about gun control then the
very least we owe them is a plan